So today I am going to do everyone’s favorite
non Newtonian experiment.
I am going to put this corn starch and water
solution on this speaker, but I want to do
this scientifically.
So I am shooting it with a high speed camera
and I am going to vary the frequency and the
amplitude and see what factors really give
us the best corn starch monster.
It still very much looks like a liquid at
this point, but as I increase the amplitude,
you can kind of tell that it is not moving
as smoothing as it should anymore.
You can see at this amplitude it starts to
jump around a little bit.
Now
I want to try to increase the frequency and
see what effect that has.
You are now at about 20 hertz, which is the
frequency recommended by some scientific papers
that have studied this phenomenon.
I’ll up the amplitude a little bit.
That is incredible.
That is awesome.
Now I am going up to about 22 hertz, seeing
nicer structures.
But it is really tough to tell, because it
is somewhat random.
Sometimes it just turns into a blob like that
and other times you get some really cool things
forming.
I am about 34 hertz here and we are not seeing
a lot of structure.
It seems like at these higher frequencies
it just sort of turns into a blob.
Interesting how it becomes more coherent and
smoother actually at the higher frequencies.
Wow.
That’s interesting.
In the high speed you can clearly see that
the inertia of the thing is keeping it off
the speaker entirely.
That is really cool.
So it is just getting kind of bumped with
that frequency.
It is not really sticking around.
That this why you probably need a lower frequency.
Oh.
Well, that is the end of that.
So how do non Newtonian fluids work?
Well, the corn starch and water is really
a suspension.
That is, these tiny little grains of starch
suspended in water.
So when you try to move that fluid slowly
the starch has time to get out of the way
of each other, because it is lubricated by
all those water molecules in between.
But if you try to get it to go fast—and
that is, there is a lot of sheer, which means
there are some places that are going faster
than others—well, then all of the starch
grains kind of get stuck up against each other.
And they can’t flow past each other.
So at that point it becomes like a solid and
less like a liquid.
You know, this kind of reminds me of traffic
in LA where I have been recently.
If there are not that many cars on the road
it is basically like having a small amount
of starch particles in your water and everything
flows very smoothly, but as soon as you get
to rush hour and you have some cars which
are trying to floor I down the highway, plus
there is all of these cars, which are like
our starch particles, on the high way, then
suddenly everything gets clogged and you are
basically in what is a solid.
So traffic might be an example of something
that is an non Newtonian fluid.
It flows very well when there aren’t very
many particles or when it is going quite slowly,
but as you try to increase the number of cars
and go really fast, then everything kind of
gets clogged up.